dieser neue raketenantrieb würde uns
nicht nur schneller zum mars bringen
sondern uns tatsächlich reisen bis an
den rand unseres sonnensystems
ermöglichen und dabei werden effekte
genutzt die aus der kernfusion stammen
es wäre eine revolution der raumfahrt
klicks um science im future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen ich bin
immer noch echt beeindruckt ihr findet
unserem podcast so cool dass er es
immerhin unter die top 20 wissenschafts
podcast in deutschland geschafft hat
mein dank gilt euch allen und ich finde
es natürlich ziemlich klasse dass ihr
euch so gut gefällt hammer und heute
werde ich nochmal etwas am podcast
schrauben er wird noch mehr inhalt
bekommen als die videos hier ich werde
heute noch ein bisschen frei von der
leber weg dort über noch ein paar rand
aspekte zum heutigen thema herum
philosophieren weil manchmal juckt es
mich einfach wenn ich hier ein video
aufnehmen und ich möchte noch mehr
loswerden und das mache ich heute zum
ersten mal im podcast also seid gespannt
mehr erfahrt ihr hier unterm oder unten
in der video beschreibung da sind die
links zu apple podcast und spotify es
war ein trauerspiel
elenas prototyp für eine maß rakete dem
starship das ist gestern abend wieder
bei der landung zerschellt dieses mal
hat die steuerung versagt und die rakete
ist in eine so starke schieflage geraten
dass sie kurz vor der landung nicht mehr
korrigiert werden konnte der prototyp
stürzte in schräglage auf die erde und
explodierte und wie schon beim ersten
mal freute sich spacex über die
gewonnenen daten es ist das große ziel
von ihnen macht die menschheit auf den
mars zu bringen er will intern also ihn
in einen fruchtbaren planeten mit einer
atmosphäre umwandeln mit sauerstoff wie
das aussieht das kann man übrigens auf
seinem twitter profil sehen aber
vielleicht werden wir auch gar nicht so
zum mars fliegen sondern ganz anders
jetzt hat nämlich das os princeton
plasmaphysik saberi ppl in den usa einen
raketenantrieb vorgestellt denn die
menschheit zum mars und darüber hinaus
bringen könnte der antrieb würde
magnetfelder anwenden um plasma partikel
elektrisch geladenes gas also im vierten
aggregatzustand der materie aus der
rakete zu schießen aufgrund des impuls
erhaltungs satzes würde das raumschiff
wie beim
herkömmlichen antrieb beschleunigt
werden solche plasma triebwerke
existieren bereits doch sie
beschleunigen das plasma mit
elektrischen feldern eine viel
schwächere kraft als die die die
physikerin fatima ebrahimi entdeckt hat
das neue konzept würde die teilchen
durch magnetische wieder verbindung re
kollektion beschleunigen das ist ein
prozess der im gesamten universum zu
finden ist und auf der sonnenoberfläche
können wir in direkt vor unserer nase
beobachten dabei laufen magnetfeldlinien
zusammen trennen sich plötzlich um sich
dann wieder zu verbinden und erzeugen
dabei eine menge energie und diese
rekorde aktion passiert auch genauso
innerhalb von donut förmigen
fusionsreaktoren den talker max fátima
ebrahimi ist flüssigeren an der
princeton university und erfinderin des
konzepts ich hatte die idee im jahr 2017
als ich auf einer terrasse saß und über
die ähnlichkeiten zwischen dem auspuff
eines autos und den hochgeschwindigkeits
abgas partikel nachdachte die von ppps
nationals ferkel torres experiment nst
ex erzeugt werden während seines
betriebs erzeugt dieser talker markt
magnetischer blasen die plasma moede
genannt werden und sich mit etwa 20
kilometern pro sekunde bewegen was mir
sehr nachschub aus st bei der kernfusion
wird die kraft genutzt die sonne und
sterne antreibt während bei
herkömmlichen kernkraftwerken atome
gespalten werden passiert bei
fusionsreaktoren das gegenteil atome
fusionieren doch dafür muss ein
widerstand überwunden werden und das
bedeutet viel druck und hohe
temperaturen
wer hier auf der welt kaum der druck auf
der sonne nachgebildet werden kann
werden deutlich höheren temperaturen
benötigt etwa 100 millionen grad bisher
sind nur sehr kurze fusionsreaktion
erzielt worden und dabei keine energie
erzeugt worden
denn das ist das prinzip der version die
fusionierten atome haben weniger masse
als ihre vorläufer der überschüssigen
teil der masse wird als energie
freigesetzt sollte die fusion aber
länger aufrechterhalten werden können
dann kann auch diese energie genutzt
werden und energie erzeugt werden und
die ist unerschöpflich dabei entstehen
viel viel weniger gefährliche abfälle
als bei heutigen kernkraftwerken und die
erzeugte energie wäre unerschöpflich was
aber schon heute in diesen reaktoren
passiert es
magnetischer blasen app sorgt und die
kann man für raketenantriebe nutzen denn
derzeitige plasma triebwerke die
elektrische felder zum antreiben der
teilchen nutzen können nur einen
geringen spezifischen impuls also eine
geringe geschwindigkeit erzeuge sprich
sie stoßen bereits plasma aus aber die
beschleunigung ist viel geringer als bei
dem neuen konzept und so können eben
auch nur geringe geschwindigkeiten
erreicht werden bei den bisherigen
antrieben computersimulationen zeigen
dass das neue plasma triebwerks konzept
das war mit geschwindigkeiten von
hunderten von kilometern pro sekunde
erzeugen kann zehnmal schneller als die
anderen triebwerke
das wäre einen riesenfortschritt für die
raumfahrt zum ersten mal hätten wir an
deutlich besseren antrieb als bisheriger
antriebe die lediglich auf der
verbrennung von gasen beruhen sie sind
extrem ineffektiv weil sie unmengen an
treibstoff erstmal ins weltall bringen
müssen und damit dann auch nur geringen
schub erzeugen können
die schnellere geschwindigkeit die mit
dem neuen antrieb für beginn der reise
eines raumschiffs erreicht werden kann
könnte die äußeren planeten in die
reichweite von raumschiffen bringen dazu
fatima ebrahimi langstrecken reisen
dauern monate oder jahre bei der
spezifische impuls chemische
raketentriebwerke sehr gering ist so
dass das raumschiff eine weile braucht
um auf geschwindigkeit zu kommen
das sagt sie aber wenn wir triebwerke
bauen die auf magnetischer re kollektion
basieren dann können wir langstrecken
missionen in kürzerer zeit durchführen
es gibt drei hauptunterschiede zwischen
ebrahim ist rückwärts konzept und
anderen antrieben der erste besteht
darin dass eine veränderung der stärke
der magnetfelder die schubkraft erhöhen
oder verringern kann indem man mehr
elektromagnete und mehr magnetfelder
verwendet kann man in der tat einen
knopf zur feinabstimmung der
geschwindigkeit drehen sagte ibrahim
zweitens erzeugt das neue triebwerk
bewegung indem es sowohl plasma teilchen
als auch magnetischer blasen also
sogenannte plasmide ausstieg die
plasmide tagen zum antrieb bei uns in
keinem anderen tipp werks konzept
enthalten
drittens im gegensatz zu aktuellen
triebwerks konzepten die auf
elektrischen feldern beruhen erlauben
die magnetischen felder in ebrach imis
konzept dass das plasma im inneren des
triebwerks entweder aus schweren oder
leichten atom bestehen kann
diese flexibilität ermöglicht es den
fachleuten die menge an schubkraft für
eine bestimmte mission anzupassen
während andere tief werke schweres gas
benötigen das aus der atom wie xenon
besteht kann man in diesem konzept jede
art von gas verwenden die man möchte
sagte baek in manchen fällen würden die
wissenschaftler leichtes gas bevorzugen
weil die kleineren atome schneller in
bewegung kommen können das extrem
spannende an dieser forschungsarbeit ist
ihre quelle
denn fusionsreaktoren haben erstmal rein
gar nichts mit raketenantrieb zu tun
dass eine physikerin daraus dann einen
raketentriebwerk entwickelt das ist
schon bemerkenswert diese arbeit wurde
vom früheren fusions arbeiten inspiriert
und es ist das erste mal dass plasmide
und re konvention für den weltraum
antrieb vorgeschlagen werden der nächste
schritt ist der bau eines prototyps
und da kommt vielleicht wieder ihre
maske ins spiel denn ein solches
unterfangen ist mit einem unglaublichen
aufwand verbunden und wenn man sich die
entwicklung von raketen in den letzten
jahren vor augen führt da hat es bisher
immer die nase vorn gehabt weder die
orion kapsel noch die große sls rakete
sind auch nur annähernd startklar
in der kapsel die jetzt liegen soll ist
offenbar ein teil defekt dessen
reparatur monate benötigt und die orion
kapsel soll eigentlich die erste crew
seit jahrzehnten wieder für mond bringen
die dragon kapsel von space expect
dagegen schon und jetzt wird sie sogar
schon für private missionen eingesetzt
ende diesen jahres sollen für
privatleute im rahmen der inspiration
for as mission die erde mehrmals
umrunden
die hochentwickelte technologie der
dragon kapsel macht es möglich ich will
mal gespannt mit welchem raum fahrzeug
und überhaupt ob jemand 2024 zum mond
fliegt wenn eine kapsel dafür allerdings
monate auseinander genommen werden muss
weil ein teil nicht funktioniert damit
zu starten kann
dann habe ich erhebliche zweifel am
zeitplan wenn nicht masse übernimmt auch
wenn bei ihm etwas schief geht dann
steht sofort der nächste prototyp bereit
und die tests gehen weiter ich bin schon
sehr gespannt auf den nächsten test von
essenzen führt den start und lande test
von starship mehr zum thema gibt es im
podcast dafür
hier klicken ich bin gespannt was er
dazu sagt also schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
bislang bleibt dran